1936 le front populaire gagne les
législatives pour revoir une gauche unie
et réentendre l'international il faut
attendre plus de 30 ans
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
1972 l'union de la gauche
cette arlésienne souvent évoqués se
concrétise enfin avec un programme
commun pour la première fois au cours
d'un meeting on a vu pulaaku la
socialiste mitterrand le communiste
marchais le radical de gauche fabre
entouré de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes
l'objectif l'elysée le candidat françois
mitterrand nous sommes laissés pour
gagner les élections
nous sommes ici pour gouverner le
chambrer c'est pour l'emporter
sauf qu'à la présidentielle de 74
mitterrand père puis c'est la rupture
entre marché et mitterrand sur la
question de la défense nationale quand
j'ai entendu françois mitterrand refusé
de s'engager sur l'existence d'une
défense nationale indépendante
j'ai dit à ma femme françois mitterrand
a décidé d'abandonner le programme
combattent à gauche ça les valises en
europe à paris maison 91 littéraux cette
fois gagne la présidentielle quatre
communistes entre gouvernement avant de
claquer la porte en 84
la gauche se disloque à nouveau nouvelle
tentative nous 997 la gauche plurielle à
la manoeuvre lionel jospin et les partis
de gauche gagne les législatives
c'est l'affichage voulu celle de l'union
retrouvée dans une majorité difficile à
conjuguer dès qu'il ya péril en la
demeure la famille de gauche se
rassemble davantage que de défendre
l'identité de chacun ses membres ont
choisi de durée ensemble mais la belle
union ne dure qu'un temps
en 2002 lionel jospin ne passe pas au
second tour de la présidentielle en
pleine soirée électorale
françois hollande tient ce héros nous
parlions de gauche plurielle c'est bien
la gauche plurielle
sauf quand elle est trop pluriel moi je
veux bien qu'on soit plus à gauche que
je veux pas non plus qu'on soit le trot
pluriel depuis l'union de la gauche est
difficile
quelques désistements lors d'élections
locales ou en 2017 quand l'écologiste
yannick jadot se retire de la course à
l'elysée pour benoît hamon et lance un
appel à jean luc mélenchon pour la
première fois l'écologie le social
l'europe et la démocratie peut gagner
une élection présidentielle alors
jean-luc parlons nous continuons à
travailler et créons cette grande
espérance autour d'un rassemblement
c'est pas facile je peux te le dire pour
moi ça n'est pas facile et bien mais
faisons le ensemble c'est pas facile et
jean luc ne le fera pas reste à voir si
cette nouvelle tentative d'union pour
2022 aboutira ou non
[Musique]